So we've got a notification appearing,
but our goal is to give the user
a button they can press to
get the latest version.
Clicking this button needs to
tell the waiting service worker
that it should take over straightaway,
bypassing the usual life cycle.
Then we want to refresh the page so
it reloads with the latest
assets from the newest cache.
There are three new components
that help us achieve this.
A service worker can call skipWaiting
while it's waiting or installing.
This signals that it shouldn't queue
behind another service worker.
It should take over straight away.
We want to call this when
the user hits the refresh button
in our update notification.
But how do we send the signal from
the page to the waiting service worker?
Your page can send messages to any
service worker using postMessage.
And you can listen for messages in the
service worker using the message event.
So, when the user clicks
the refresh button it
will send a message to our service
worker telling it to call skip waiting.
And the final part, we've already seen
navigator.serviceworker.controller but
the page gets an event
when its value changes,
meaning a new service
worker has taken over.
We're going to use this as a signal
that we should reload the page.